the Minh City Karnas in Croydon in South
London this morning and we can speak to
him now mayor thank you for joining us
you know the numbers in your patch have
gone up hugely you're responsible for
policing under the laws and rules have
you done enough to solve this problem of
knife crime well we did we can in London
I've been saying for the last two years
we need much more support from the
government in terms of resources and
powers to invest in preventive services
and also in place and notwithstanding
the government doing nothing tangible to
help us from City Hall we've got a huge
amount that continues to do a huge
amount in relation to resources I've
increased council tax in my first three
years than maximum I am allowed to do
but also our divergent business rates to
invest in young people and also in our
police and we have fewer police officers
in London now in 2019 than any time
since 2003 our population has grown by a
mere and a half since 2003 but also when
it comes to youth services over the last
eight years dozens and dozens of you
sentence have closed down hundreds of
youth workers have lost their jobs
thousands of young people who used to
have youth centres to go to happen we're
do now best to fill this hole by
ourselves though we can't do it now you
will have seen or you may have seen the
Metropolitan Police Commissioner
Crushers dick making some comments on
the role of police cuts numbers cuts
let's just play that clip from Krishna
dick from early this morning in the last
few years police officers numbers have
gone down a lot there's been a lot of
cuts in other public services there's
been more demand for policing and
therefore there must be something can I
have consistent using I agree that there
is some link between violent crime on
the streets obviously and the planned
police numbers of course there isn't I
think everybody would would see that
so Marilyn what's your response to the
Maryland police commissioner there well
I agree with the Met Police Commissioner
absolutely and bother if he speak to
chief constables around the country
maybe speak to police and crime
commissioners around the country if you
speak too sensible conservative
politicians privately they all agree by
the Home Office officials also agree of
course there's a link between the number
of police officers and crime going up
the home office themselves except this
of course there's a link between youth
centers having massive cuts manhood
services having massive cuts schools
having massive cuts Children Services
having massive cuts and young people
have been less constructive things to do
I'm not excused criminality but there
are there are complex reasons why
violent crimes gone up there are
deep-seated social problems lack of
opportunities poverty social alienation
mental health issues exacerbated by the
massive cuts from the government in
London alone in London alone our Police
Service has already lost 850 million
pounds over the last eight years on top
of that the government's making a
further cuts of 200 million pounds over
the next two years so I think there's a
link I've been saying for the last two
years there's a link and the government
needs to wake up reverse these cuts in
that police but also our preventative
Services - but I mean you're giving
yourself a free pass don't you set the
priorities as part of the devolution
settlements for policing in your patch
if you think that this was more of a
priority surely you could have diverted
some of the funding into my crime we all
it's just worth for - look in 2010
central government the Chancellor at the
time made massive cuts to police and a
billion pounds from the Met Police in
the first six years of 2010 2016 the
previous mayor refused to raise council
tax refused to divert resources away to
police in our youth services I became
there in May 2016 I raised the maximum
council axe I was allowed to do by law
in 2017 2018 and now 2019 on top of that
I've been invested in police by increase
in business race so we've now started
recruiting
more police but it won't fill the hole
left behind we've lost thousands of
police officers thousands of Kimmi
officers thousands of police staff
dozens of youth centers hundreds of
youth workers have lost their jobs now
for the prime minister and the Hong SEC
to now cry crocodile tears tears is no
consolation we need rapid investment now
but also the promised herself to lead
the work required to grapple with the
issue of the increase in life produced
in London by the way in Manchester in
Birmingham in Liverpool in Cardiff all
across the country I mean people's
families are suffering up and down the
country people don't want this political
blame game other than funding what is
the solution is there this public health
approach that I think has been tried in
Scotland absolutely we've learnt lessons
from Glasgow and Chicago as well here in
London
we have England's first public health
approach taking place with a new violin
selection unit we're bringing it
together not just at City Hall and the
police but also the NHS schools social
services run important that the
charity's involved civil society
involved education is a big role to play
too many young people are being excluded
from schools I've got no say there we're
trying to bring schools to go to work
with us question the effectiveness of
the pupil Referral Units really really
important also we know that young people
who see in their homes domestic abuse
and domestic violence when they are
older get involved in violent crime
these are called adverse childhood
experiences we've got the team from
Glasgow helping us and this week the new
director of the VIU began in her role so
in London where we're leading the way
showing what can be done but resources
are important you know we can talk about
all the other things we're doing so
removing this silence means we can
become the resources working together
so rather than budgets working in silos
we can try and pull resources where do
we can but I've got to say this is in
the context of no tangible assistance
coming from central government a police
officers work so hard they're over
stretched they're under-resourced we
speak to a teacher he speak to a youth
worker he speaks those in A&E they work
so hard
we now have youth workers in trauma
centre than any
he's trying to work with young people
who go to A&E I've been victims of
crimes fine turned them around if
they're involved in criminal gangs the
so-called teachable moment we're
supporting charities from the San Giles
trust to reference this community center
I'm here with Croydon BMF forum we're
supporting them as well so look we're
trying to fill the massive hole left by
central government but in irrespective
of the cuts from central government
occurring in London do not bet to keep
young people safe